hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested uh not this
game in particular but you wanted me to
check up on being lyran and inform you
guys on uh how he's doing in um
qualifying for the candidates tournament
all the other spots of the candidates
tournament have been filled and now we
are waiting for ding to finish uh
playing all of his games uh so this is
the last game he played in the hangzhou
grand master tournament and now he
already started a six game match against
wei yi uh we're gonna discuss that uh
after we check out the game uh but uh
first let's focus on this and then we're
gonna check out on how he did in this
tournament and then what is uh what is
up uh with ding next and how he will be
able to finally qualify for the
candidates tournament so let's check it
out the game is very very interesting
it's um uh well uh it's it's an opening
you guys know all too well it's the
catalan opening but the the line that
the ding chooses against the opening is
uh something um
well not everyone can employ it's very
very tricky and you really have to know
what you're doing so let's check it out
and see uh how it wins uh he's playing
against uh xu xiangyu another uh
chinese grand master and uh for those of
you who are maybe interested in that uh
shu in chinese means brilliant rising
sun i
was checking up on how to how to
properly pronounce chinese names and
then i also stumbled upon this so maybe
if you guys are interested in that
now you know uh so let's see how it went
uh shu opens uh with c4 so we open uh
sorry not with c4 with d4 uh we have
knight to f6 biting c for e6 and knight
to f3 and d5 the queen's gambit declined
is on the board and we have g3 the
catalan opening uh bishop to b for check
by ding knight b to d2 and now d
captures on c4 so this is all very
standard stuff and now usually white
will just fianchetto the catalan bishop
here with bishop to g2 but xu goes for
a3 now first challenge is things bishop
asking are you maybe interested in
capturing on d2
and dingus this is considered the main
line against this uh this line bishop
captures on d2 bishop captures and
bishop to d7 now uh here we have e3
opening up
an attack towards the c4 pawn and now uh
everyone played the bishop to b5 in this
position but the ding plays
sorry not b6 ding plays b5 and it is now
already as of move 8 that we have a
completely new game and if you've seen
any catalan games you know how dangerous
it can be to open up this diagonal for
this light square bishop so let's see
how white
goes about this b5 idea now the real
problem uh
behind b5 is yes you are defending your
c for pawn at the moment but white can
very easily undermine this structure
with a move like b3 or a4 now it's only
a matter of what white will do here if
you try a4 then the idea is just a
castle
that's the point and now after knight e5
preparing bishop to g2 we play c5
challenge white center and finally after
bishop to g2 we can put a knight on d5
and now
black is very very comfortable
comfortable here uh he equalized without
much trouble and if something's like a
captures we're still going to play
bishop captures on b5 and now uh what
can you play d captures on c5 a5 and the
white blacks a5 and the c4 pawns are
incredibly strong here and the black can
be very happy with himself so instead
after b5 uh our shoe decides to
challenge ring structure with b3 being
captures here we have queen captures and
now a6 now the b5 pawn is defended and
again you are very very uh happy about
your position so knights the e5
preparing bishop to g2 and now ding
plays knight to c6 and this is uh the
kind of trickery that you have to know
in order to play this line would have
moved like b5 uh bishop to g2 attacking
the knight and now how are you saving
your knight obviously if you move it uh
bishop captures on a8 is coming but not
really here ding just captures the
knight and now the problem is if bishop
captures an a8 notice that the white
king still hasn't castled we're just
going to play queen captures attack the
rook and black just wins here if you
move the rook then even knight to f3
check and this is just unplayable for
white
uh so after knight captures an e5 we
first have to capture
attacking the knight and the rook but
the ding defends everything very easily
by playing knight to d5 and now uh here
we have bishop to a5 another great move
by xu because uh well it seems like you
could capture on d5 but not really this
is uh
not possible if captures captures and
captures we can just castle here and now
how are you playing this with white uh
if you don't castle just bishop to h3
will be a huge problem and if you cancel
then it's still a huge problem just
bishop to h3 now your rook is hanging
and also your queen is hanging so you
might
trade queens here but it doesn't really
matter now the bishop is hanging also
the rook
is being attacked and if rook d1 bishop
g4 and that's it there's no way out of
this for white so uh that's why bishop
to a5 we're gonna put pressure on the c5
pawn because we still know that c5 has
to be played at some point so here we
have castles biting and castles by shoe
we have a queen to c8 now preparing to
push the pawn to c5 the pawn is no
longer pinned and now rook a to c1 we
have c5 now the past c pawn is marching
forward
but this also means that you will have
to give up a pawn in order to do this uh
so bishop captures on d5 uh she accepted
the challenge e captures and queen
captures on d5 and now c4 so ding
continues pushing the pass pawn and now
uh here comes a move that you might not
expect but f3 is in is really a very
strong move the problem is of course
white would want to win the the open d
file it seems like a great idea but if
you play something like rook after d1
then we can play bishop to c6 just move
the bishop out of the way grab hold of
this diagonal and now you have to be
very careful of what you do otherwise
queen h3 will be a huge trouble so queen
c5 can be played okay now queen can't go
to h3 because the bishop is hanging but
now bishop to f3 and again black is the
one who is going to win the e file sorry
the d file and now let's say queen
captures we're going to play rook
captures on c8 and now rook to d7 as the
rook was attacked you bring the rook to
the seventh rank but still rook f8 we
attacked the e5 pawn and after some like
bishop to c3 now we play rook e to d8
and now it's definitely black who will
win the e uh the d file the bishop
covers the d1 square so not a lot of fun
for white you're gonna have to play a
passive move like bishop to d4 just not
uh
allow black to completely win the d file
and it's uh well a better position for
black so instead after c4 we have f3 now
the bishop will not be
as powerful on this diagonal and now
rook to e8 we put pressure on the e5
pawn and now comes rook c to d1 here
a proper way to play this with white
would be something like queen d4 move
the queen out of this diagonal and then
play uh e4 and then the light square
bishop will not be such a big deal but
after rook c to d1 the problem is now
okay the bishop is attacked but the ding
just moves it with tempo attacks the
rook here and now you don't have the d1
square for this rook and well now you
have to play out of rook to e1 or rook
after uh f2 a rook f2 f2 is played and
now another uh great move by ding uh
rook to a7 uh so you can see that now
currently white controls the d file as
the bishop controls v8 the queen and
rook or everyone controls the d8 square
the problem is there's no way for white
to actually use this because now rook to
d7 will be uh well
is a huge problem for white so white
stops this we have g4 now the bishop no
longer guards the d7 square and the
bishop might be
somewhat misplaced here but not really
now ding could continue with something
like rook 887 to go after the e5 pawn
but now ding says all right you've
made a hole in front of your king time
to open up the white king's position h5
now we're threatening to just start
grabbing on g4
and here
is the moment where white really could
make a difference in the game but he has
to play a very precise move in the move
you might even want to pause the video
try to find the absolute best move for
white here it doesn't even give white a
good position it's just the absolute
best that white has so
while i give you a couple of seconds
uh for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
hidden resource that was missed in the
actual game and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is pawn
to e6 we make use of this pawn being on
h5 now we're threatening to pick up the
h5 pawn also we're putting some pressure
on this f7 square
but the the position is much much more
complicated than you might uh you might
imagine now the the the actual line goes
h captures on g4 now we don't really
gain anything by capturing on f7 because
the rook also guards that but there's
queen to d7 now good luck finding this
after e6 so
of course i should probably consider the
e6 but if you don't find queen to d7 you
don't really get all that much out of
this line rook captures on these seven
now pawn captures on d7 and now it seems
like okay you're gonna capture something
here but not really you're not going for
that you're going for pawn to d8 because
the bishop and the rook will be covering
the d8 square so here black's best
option is to just play something like
queen captures on d7 and after rook
captures on d7 it seems that now white
is completely winning but ding would
have a hidden resource here that is g3
attacking both of the rooks this is uh
uh well one of the craziest line that
was not playing the played in the game
that we've seen in a while and now after
you move one of the rooks let's say rook
d1 you're gonna capture here king
captures and now you get this uh
position where it's uh it's an endgame
ding would be upon bishops of opposite
color so black is a little bit better
probably not enough to push for
something so congratulations to everyone
who found this uh it was missed in the
game rook f2d2 was played fully gaining
control of the open d file now uh the
default definitely belongs to white but
again this is only
uh
it only appears that way so now dink
could again go after the e pawn but he
goes uh h captures on g4 he wants to
open up the position in front of the
white king now comes queen to e4 a very
dangerous move now threatening rook to
d8 but now c3 attacking the rook here
rook to d8 and the knockouts pawn to c2
a complete madness on the board what's
the uh i mean
what's even happening here so the thing
is you can't really capture the queen
because then black captures the rook on
d1 and promotes his pawn to a queen with
check so this would be completely
winning the only move that white has is
rook captures rook with check we have
queen captures rook on e8 and now queen
captures on c2 so eliminating this past
pawn and now uh rook to d7 so even
though white had complete control of the
d file it was never really
there to for for white to take advantage
of
and now you have to decide whether you
play f4 to keep uh keep an eye on your
e5 pawn or you play f captures on g4
which was played in the game bishop
captures on g4 and not rook to d4 hoping
that uh dink capture so you can undouble
your pawns and maybe start pushing your
pass deep on but this is uh in fact
strongest for dings so rook captures e
captures and now queen to a8 and
although the material is completely
equal the bishops are of opposite colors
and the whenever you have bishops of
opposite colors it is always um
better for the side who's attacking
because you have a queen and the light
square bishop if you're attacking the
white king your opponent's dark square
bishop will not be able to help
the defender the king because you are
attacking the light squares and the dark
square bishop will be completely useless
here of course white could also utilize
this tactic however the black king is
much much safer
so how do you go about this with queen
to d3 not allowing ding to infiltrate
with queen to f3 also preparing to push
your pawn here and now while dink could
stop this with bishop to e6 you gain
full control over the d5 square it's a
light square
actually only has a dark square bishop
so you are not crossing that ding in
fact goes for queen to d5 he blocks the
pawn completely this way and keeps the
bishop on uh well very active attacking
square that is the g4 square so bishop
to b4 now comes bishop to d7
uh we have king to f2 uh not much you
can do now white uh black will start
activating his queen so king f2 and then
now comes bishop to c6
and uh this is now uh incredibly
incredibly difficult for white to play
with perfect play this could even be a
draw but with the white king so wide
open it's just not something that you
that you ever want to play especially
against someone like ding uh it would be
tough playing this against anyone but
against the ding it's just uh well close
to impossible so king e3 we have queen
to f3 with chuck king to d2 and now
queen f2 with check king c3 uh now comes
queen captures an h2 ding wins upon but
okay still it's bishops of opposite
colors so bishop to d6 now making some
room for the king to hide maybe on the
queen side and the queen to h1 now we
have king to b4 now ding delivers
another check queen e1 check forcing the
king of the board king to c5 and do not
bishop the e4 uh forcing the the white
queen to a less active square queen to
b3 and then now comes queen to c1 with
check king b6 and queen to c6 with check
king to a5 if you go to a7 of course you
get checkmate that queen to b7 will be
checkmate so king a5 your only option
and now the ship to d5 forcing the white
queen further back so queen to b4 uh it
looks uh and maybe too dangerous to put
a queen on b4 because that's the only
square you have for your king to escape
luckily uh there's no square for the
link to deliver check if dean could
maybe play queen to d8 to check it'd be
game over so uh here first ding plays
queen to c bishop to c4 if you try
something like uh queen here to maybe
try and deliver this checkmate we're
just gonna play queen c5 so we're gonna
prepare for this now if you deliver
checkmate we can easily block it so
instead we have bishop to c4
and now comes queen to c5 attacking the
queen and now queen to b7
uh so just getting out of the way but
still keeping all the pressure with
bishop the c7 and now king to h7 so now
ding puts the king on a safer square and
he is ready to start pushing his past g
pawn so
the sort of a principle of two
weaknesses one weakness being the uh
wide open a white king on a5 so white
will have to keep the queen or at least
the bishop there to to prevent checkmate
but still even if just the bishop is
here the black queen will have too easy
a time attacking it so the white queen
will also have to help out so it's not
going to be easy stopping the past g
pawn while also defending against
checkmate so here queen e7 uh and queen
to e for now uh we have queen back to c5
white can't really do anything you can
just wait and see what happens and now
g5 ding starts pushing the pass pawn uh
king captures on a6 but now g4 so we
give up upon in the queen set but we
continue pushing on the uh on the king
side and the material is equal now but
still very very hard to defend this with
white we have king to a7 uh now comes
bishop to e6 and this is a
very important move before you we
continue pushing because uh a4 will be a
problem you will not be able to capture
b captures on a4 because the bishop
would be hanging so first ding prepares
it bishop to e6 and now
we have bishop to b6 if you go for queen
captures on b5 then g3 and you are not
stopping this pawn once it gets to g2
it's a on a defended square and you know
you will very easily get to promote this
pawn so instead after bishop e6 with
bishop to b6 but still g3
we have d5 now we have to give up a pawn
in order to
guard this diagonal so d5 uh bishop
captures on the e5 and now queen to c3
now going after the pawn but also if the
pawn is pushed maybe you can start
giving some checks however the position
is now completely winning for ding so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for ding while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well pretty much an instant win and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's queen to a4 with check i don't
enjoy using pause the video moments that
start with check but here uh it also
involves spotting a very very
interesting idea behind the queen a4
check you could also play queen c4
that's perfectly fine but queen day for
check is just much much faster so
congratulations to everyone who decided
this uh the point is you have to uh
realize that the end game if the queens
get off the board is winning for black
so imagine queen a5 we're gonna capture
bishop captures now king g6 we're going
to play bishop to c3 to try and stop the
past pawn but now king f5 we're
threatening king e4 so bishop cannot
come to d4 so bishop to d4 right away
but still king e4 and now you can't keep
an eye on the g1 square end on the pawn
and once you move king captures here of
course now uh black is just up two pawns
completely winning so that's the idea
behind queen a for check if the queen
blocks uh so what what can you do bishop
to a5 is played and now we have kinked
uh
sorry pawn to g2 just advancing the
spawn now we're threatening to bring a
queen into the game and the ding had to
calculate that queen to h3 will not
result in some sort of a perpetual so
queen to h3 would check king g6 we have
queen to d3 with check now comes king g5
queen to e3 with check king to g4 and
now you don't have queenie to check
because then the bishop blocks with
bishop to f3 and then no more checks for
you so king the b8 was played uh just
you know for good measure because
there's really no move here that white
can play uh king to beat was played and
ding just picked up the bishop and uh
well it was sort of a a stylish way for
shu to resign this game so a brilliant
brilliant
game by both of them but ding
got the upper hand in this one and he
doesn't only win this game but he also
wins the tournament with a brilliant
brilliant score uh of 10 and a half out
of 12. so out of 12 games he won nine
games and drew only three games which is
uh really incredible and uh
here you can see that uh
he won quite a lot of rating points he
won 10.8 rating points and he is now on
the live ratings list uh he is a second
uh behind magnus carlsen let me just
so you can see everything uh he's now
second on the uh affiliate live rating
list with 2809 overtaking ferruja who
was uh
number two uh before ding started his uh
uh well uh new ascent uh and uh well he
he just has to play enough games but
he's also winning raiding uh so uh that
will be great and if he manages to play
all of the games he will
be a great great candidate of the
next candidates tournament and here you
can see
i told you let me just load this up
since i haven't prepared it sorry about
this we said the ding already started
his match against wei yi so here's a
nice photo of that uh let me just uh fix
this a little bit
uh against wei yi uh this is the first
game already being played uh while i was
recording this the game was still in
progress it might have finished already
so we're probably going to show a few
games from this match as well uh this is
just for you to to check out the setting
uh so there you have it let's enjoy that
for a little bit wei you of china rated
27 29 against dingler and uh who is
still 27 um 99 as this is only the live
ratings list
uh so yeah there we have it uh very very
nicely done by ding uh we'll see if he
will be the the last candidate of the
candidates tournament or will something
completely unexpected happen and we will
have to look for a replacement for ding
yet again
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it and that you were
successful in spotting those two
positive video moments correctly uh i
would like to thank uh christian jonot
uh matthew chestnut uh murmur's gambit
open c smokey duel and open c smokey
doula for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on
how things doing
and of course checking up on your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day